- There's tons of
stuff that I do and,
some of it takes off,
some of it doesn't,
but what is really amazing
about the 2017 Flip Challenge...
Is Trouty in the shot?
Get him out of here.
(DRock laughs)
No no, I mean,
keep it rolling but,
like you can sit, I mean
just go focus on me,
'cause I don't want him
to get any more face time.
What's really
amazing is when...
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("The City" by Bazanji)
- [Gary] Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and it's episode 251
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Pretty excited about this
because I'm a huge NBA fan,
and we have a real life
NBA player here with us.
Mason Plumlee is here.
What part of your game
was toughest for you?
If you said, at a macro,
the thing that was hardest
for you to develop,
in your game,
that you can rewind to now,
like we're going very
macro basketball right now,
what would that be?
- So last summer
I wanted to change
the way in which I shot
the ball, my form and--
- Period?
- Period, yeah, so like--
- Well that's, a little crazy.
- Yeah, and I, well it's
crazy if you have something,
I always felt like this,
Tiger Woods broke down a
swing that had won Masters,
he re-worked it.
- Right.
- I wasn't breaking
down a shot that worked.
I was breaking down a
shot that didn't work.
- I love it.
- I wanted to change my
form and so the thing is--
- And?
- you know, it was very...
There were a lot of
times I didn't see progress,
I didn't, you know,
I got with the coach
and we were in the gym every
day, and it was frustrating.
The stuff felt
awkward, it didn't,
you have muscle memory and
habits that are hard to break
if you've been doing
them wrong for so long.
So, that was something
that I just fully
committed to last summer.
- And?
- Like the question said, there
were a lot of times where--
- But where are we right now?
- You know
I feel very, I'm still--
- In it?
- I'm still in it,
I'm still on that journey,
I'm very happy
with where my form is.
You know, I hit more
jump shots this year,
than I have any year
in the league, and that's,
now I feel like
I have a base and a form
that I can build on,
and continue to improve.
- Mason, I'm glad
you stopped by man.
- Thanks for having me.
("The City" by Bazanji)
- 30 with him on the front and
back, or something like that?
When you think long term,
you run better businesses,
you're a better human
being, and in this clip,
you'll see me
talking passionately about...
Yeah one more time,
here's a little rant,
you can show all that stuff Ty,
maybe you can speed it up,
and then maybe
show little parts.
What you just
witnessed was how I create.
When you feel it, do it.
Came up with a little idea,
never thought about it before,
excited what's
going on with my podcast,
let me gamify it, create
that little piece of content.
And this little one-minute
Facebook or Instagram,
or whatever video,
if it goes that long,
is about this, which is you
need to act on when you feel it.
So if you feel something,
you act on it,
this is just meta on top of
meta on top of meta, right?
Like I just felt it, I did it,
and now I'm making
another piece of content
about what I just
did because I feel it.
Always react and do.
The amount of people that just
had an idea to do a contest
on their podcast to grow
awareness on their podcast,
but then will have
six meetings, ponder it,
and never get around
to doing it, is very high.
The difference for me as an
operator, is when I feel it,
I just go into do mode.
I felt it right now,
and I did it for the podcast.
I felt that there
was a learn lesson in it,
and I'm making an
original video piece of content.
Do, do, do.
If you really understand
what just happened with this
video clip, you've got a shot.
Cool awesome, okay...
("Cocoa" by Common Souls)
Make the list of questions
and people, and fucking,
we're gonna win, man.
Like you got, it's actually
such a basic system, just...
- [Tyler] It really is.
- It really is, it's just
hard to wrangle the tiger,
but make the fucking
list and just fucking...
And you're in charge
of me, like 15 minutes,
if it's in my schedule
- Also then just be...
- [Gary] So I was a
D and F student,
and was an immigrant that
came to America with nothing,
so it makes sense for
me to hear you say that,
because that's what
happened to me, in my early 20s.
I didn't have
anything, you know,
I didn't have any success
that I could hang my hat on,
or relationships, or even,
I didn't even know like
what Ivy League
school kids looked like.
I'm telling you
like real extreme,
so when I started
getting in my 20s
and building my
wine business, I,
you know I had it in me,
but I was like, wait a minute,
it's even happening to me now.
By the way, this will
continue to happen to you,
if you're actually an intuitive
base winner, even now,
like listen,
when I hang out with
fancy smancy people I'm like,
I'm smarter than these people,
like in the game that's
being played now, right?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Like, well honestly that's,
honestly to be very frank,
that's what caught my attention.
To me, it's art.
- [Woman] Mhmmm.
Yeah.
- [Gary] It's DNA,
it's like no different
than you having brown eyes.
It's like either you
have it, it's binary.
- [Woman] It's just right
now I feel like we're on the
precipice of so
much change here.
- We are.
- [Woman] In all
industries and--
- Because we're all being
changed by the same thing.
- [Woman] Yeah, and so
everything is becoming
multi-faceted and--
- Correct, it's layered.
- [Woman] Like nothing
is no longer just a platform,
it's also a brand.
- Unemotional truth to
the reality of the situation.
Fuck. That's how I am,
like I would turn this into
a pumpkin patch
selling company tomorrow
if I thought it
was the right thing.
I mean it.
When you are in a place
where you become
completely unemotional
and all you're doing
is reacting to culture,
like I don't need to,
I don't care if the Migos
is shit, or bad, or good.
Or if Atlanta, if Danny Glover
of Childish Gambino
is good, bad, or indifferent,
I just care that people care.
- [Woman] Mhmmm.
- I don't get to decide.
The market does.
So I think the brands that
are able to capture a moment
are the ones that intrigue me.
The ones that actually
capture my attention
are the ones who can show me
that it's their absolute thesis,
not the one time that
got them to make the money.
- Thanks for meeting me.
- Of course brother.
- I had a meeting with Nick,
and I still
fucking love it here.
Got an amazing little team.
- That's the game.
That's not a, this is my title.
It just becomes this one
version of the same game,
being an art
lead back in the day,
when you were
wherever, however, right?
When I'm an art
director it'll be different,
it's not different.
- Nah, not at all.
(laughs)
- And guess what, even
when you get to the end,
the only difference
is I don't have a boss,
everybody becomes your boss.
It like, all the way up,
and then you think,
no, no, no,
it goes the other way,
and the whole
thing flips on you,
and everybody's above you.
Like, think about that, right.
(crosstalk)
Right, right?
And what people don't get
is when you get to the top,
so everyone's
like, oh I'm down here,
and one day I'm gonna be up
here, and I'm gonna be a boss
and it's gonna
be better, and then,
like we just said, it's not.
And then they think,
but one day,
I'm gonna run my own
design shop, one day.
What you don't understand is
when you actually
make it to the top
the whole thing flips on you,
and then everybody's above you.
- And your whole
team's a client because--
- The junior designer
in this fucking company,
I report to more people
than that person does.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- It's fucking gnarly,
but it's dope,
like if you've got the chops.
("The Plan" by Rey Topal)
It's more macro than that.
It's a never-ending
game of a box.
People's opinions
form over time.
That's all.
- [Man] But I break people.
- I get it.
- [Man] Like more having so--
- Because you act.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Acting is the
only way to do it.
I break people too.
- [Man] Act as in take action?
- Correct.
- [Man] Got it.
- Yeah not like put up a front.
- [Man] Of course.
- You're authentically
your awesome self.
This is not your schtick.
- [Man] Yeah.
- This is your truth.
- [Man] And that would have
been revealed a long time ago
if it was.
- Me too which is why everybody
pisses me off so much.
("The Plan" by Rey Topal)
How long have you been here?
- [Man 2] Since
mid-November.
Right after the Diageo project.
- Love it.
Very awesome.
I'm building this
for the rest of my life.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] What do I want to make?
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- I want to make the fucking
motion picture of my life.
- [Man 2] Right.
Perfect.
- Like I wanna make
content that sells
eight million raised glasses.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- I wanna make a
animated 17 minute film
that wins an academy award.
I wanna make
a VR 360 experience
that nobody's ever made before.
And it's critically acclaimed.
But sold bagels for a
fucking store in St. Louis.
- [Man 2] Right.
- I wanna make a
video that's $700
and changes Schenectady,
New York's entire POV
to the world
cause it went viral.
- [Man 2] Right.
- I wanna do everything.
Have a great weekend, man.
- [Man 2] Alright, thank you.
- Anything I can
ever help, reach out.
- [Man 2] Okay. Yeah,
I really appreciate it.
Thanks, Gary.
- My pleasure man.
I'm glad you came over.
- [Man] Yeah.
- I'll see you soon.
("The Plan" by Rey Topal)
- Yeah I mean
that's the game, right?
What do you need from me?
Great.
Understood.
I know that it's in my inbox.
Send the (censored).
Resend that.
I will give you a firm
financial number on Tuesday.
Right?
- [Woman 2] Yes.
- Like right?
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- [Woman 3] Our office.
- The views are just so sick.
- We have the best spot.
- I honestly think
this is the best spot.
Nothing.
I know there's
Madison Square Garden.
That's like where my
knowledge of this city ends.
(group laughs)
- And it's literally
changing our company.
- Yeah. I mean I think--
- We will never loose if I
meet with every single person.
("The Plan" by Rey Topal)
- Dude, that tweet you put
out last night or this morning
had me so fired up.
(Jocko laughs)
Work, work, work right?
So what we basically
believe in the same shit.
- [Jocko] Yeah.
- I love it.
- Yeah, same shit.
In fact there's some shit
where I hear you
say it and I go damn.
- [Gary] That's a different
way to say some, yeah.
- [Jocko] Yeah different
but saying the same thing.
I'm doing what I'm doing.
I got that book coming out.
- Thank you.
- When?
- [Jocko] This book
comes out May 2nd.
It's a kid's book.
Teaching kids how to work.
- Dude, you
know what's so crazy?
You are the best.
Because this is literally what
I've been
talking with them about.
I'm coming out
with a kid's cartoon.
- Beautiful.
- I believe in this shit.
- Yeah. So that
comes out on May 2nd.
- So May 2nd.
- Tuesday.
- So, oh fuck Tuesday.
- Yeah, around the corner.
- Link it up.
My man Jocko's got a book.
Go get it for all your kids.
Awesome.
Jocko, I wish you well man.
- Yeah man, thanks.
- Thanks for stopping by.
- Appreciate it.
- We'll hang, maybe
I'll see you Tuesday.
- Yeah, we'll work it out.
- Sid.
- Don't ask me to
do something on camera.
- Sid, what the fuck, dude?
(group laughter)
- I can't do this.
- You suck, Sid.
- Oh Sid you got lucky.
It got photoed out.
- Awwww.
- That's right, he's got it.
(group laughter)
- Alright I gotta fill...
Tyler, we'll
see Jocko on Tuesday.
Let's go.
See ya, Jock.
- [Tyler] The shakes?
- [Gary] Yeah probably.
So I don't eat
too much, ya know?
- [Tyler] So you don't
eat too much right?
- [Gary] Yeah,
but I wanna eat some.
Hey guys.
- [Woman 3] We're folding
boxes to send to influencers.
- This really makes me
happy to be very frank.
- [Woman 3] Well good.
- This feels very much like
the kind of
company I wanted to build.
- [Woman 3] And we're sending
murdery things to people so.
(group laughter)
- [Gary] That part...
(laughs)
Alright, mock me.
- [AJ] Awesome, that was quick.
Luke, you don't scare me.
I don't think you'd
beat me in anything in life.
Just so you understand where my...
That synthesizes everything
which is I don't know
how to answer your question
because I don't know
if they just have a moment
or they've proven to me.
Bezos has proven to me.
He's unemotional.
- [Woman 4] Mhmmm.
You know?
He will innovate to the death.
- [Woman 4] Mhmmm.
- And he believes in his thesis.
Same with me.
The reason I'm
building this company
is to build the scalable
version of my behavior.
Which is Mars, let's go.
Let's go buy up
all the outdoor media
'cause at first
that will be valuable.
So I trade attention.
Hacking culture.
Like knowing what the
fuck is actually happening.
Either I know what's happening
in Silicon Valley
for real or I don't.
Either you get tricked and think
you have to have an
opinion on glass EA.
You have to have an
opinion on Conde Nast.
opinion on Snapchat and Nike.
You have to have an opinion.
And either you're
right or you're wrong.
And what I try to
spend almost all my time on
is being right.
It's all about that.
- [Woman 4] Mhmmm.
- You can never
waiver from your opinion
because first of all,
either you're good
enough or you're not.
And it actually doesn't matter
what they think right now.
- [Woman 4] Mhmmm.
That's fascinating.
- I think so.
- [Woman 4] Yeah.
- It's really fascinating.
I basically play an entire life
that doesn't value the current.
- [Woman 4] Mhmmm.
- And so you
know what that means?
It means you get to
be religious about it
and you never waiver.
- [Woman 4] Mhmmm.
("Fireworks" by JMKM)
- Joe Klecko.
Here comes the pick.
("Fireworks" by JMKM)